[Music]
first i'd like to thank the incredible
production team on waters world you guys
are the best and make everything look
perfect on air
and thanks to the technical team our
director stage manager for all your very
hard work and of course thanks to hair
and makeup especially hair and makeup
water's world has had ups and downs and
covered a wild stretch over the last
five to six years as you just saw from
obama to trump to biden
your world i'm sure has been just as
nuts
but we did this together and we'll stay
together
as we close this chapter on saturday
night
turn to the next chapter with me
starting monday january 24th at 7 pm
eastern when we launch jesse waters
prime time
thank you for choosing to spend saturday
nights with me
i have a feeling we'll be spending even
more time together i love you
and as always
always remember this
i'm waters
and this is my world hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else